es ist ein absoluter schock für den
jüdischen sänger guildo war ihm am
montagabend wird der 39 jährige wegen
des anhängers an seiner halskette am
hotel the westin leipzig abgewiesen der
unfassbare grund das schmuckstück zeigt
einen davidstern wir haben ja bereits
gestern hier darüber berichtet der
39-jährige und ganz deutschland sind
fassungslos und über diesen vorfall
wollen wir jetzt mit ihm persönlich
sprechen eher gering ist uns live
zugeschaltet hallo erfahren
wie guten morgen hallo
fühlen sie sich noch wohl fühlen sie
sich noch sicher in diesem land
heißt ja ich kann es nur wiederholen es
ist nicht der erste vorfall in meinem
leben an denen ich kontakt kunden mit
mit fremdenhass über jugend hast oder
antisemitismus aber ich glaube es war
einmal zu viel und ich bin froh dass ich
das gemacht habe ich
finde man soll einfach nicht nur die
klappe halten und das über sich ergehen
lassen ich habe mir nur gewünscht dass
ich nicht alleine gewesen mir in dem
moment als ich mir gewünscht dass andere
gäste das vielleicht mit gehört hätten
oder bzw sogar
hat sich das hotel denn schon bei ihnen
gemeldet gibt es dahingehend eine
reaktion
ich habe das management hat nur eine e
mail bekommen dass man sich mal
austauschen wollen würde mal reden aber
ich habe weder eine stellungnahme
bekommen zu diesem fall ich habe keine
entschuldigung bekommen gar nichts
herr offer und schildern sie uns doch
den vorfall noch einmal aus ihrer sicht
ich habe in leipzig eine eine
fernsehshow gehabt und wurde dann am
abend ist total und fahren zum check-in
und es war eine relativ lange schlange
auch in der lobby weil irgendwie habe
ich der computer beim check-in spielte
ich weiß es nicht und einige gäste waren
schon genervt jedenfalls ich habe
gemerkt dass dieser mann vom check in
schalter auch immer durch die lobby
gehen und ich habe gemerkt dass ja immer
eine person nach der anderen von hinten
nach vorne getan und ich hab irgendwann
mal sich dran war gefragt entschuldigung
gibt es hier unterschiede was ist hier
los ich verstehe nicht warum wollen sie
die leute von hinten nach vorne dann
sagte er mir um die schlange zu
entzerren
aber ich habe es nicht verstanden ich
habe mich doch auch angestellt und die
anderen gäste auch und dann kam der
spruch von der seite irgendwo von
jemandem den stern weg und ich war
fassungslos und schon ein mann an und er
sagte das gleiche auch noch mal und
ich hatte mir einfach den mund
aufgemacht hatte das müssen ja andere
mitbekommen haben niemand hat
irgendetwas gesagt
und wie schwer fiel ihnen dann die
entscheidung zu sagen ich setze mich
ganz vors hotel und macht das öffentlich
postet das bei instagram und wie sind
die reaktionen vor allem darauf
ich noch mal ich habe in der
vergangenheit auch darüber gesprochen
dass antisemitismus wirklich weg war
sondern es ist nämlich mittlerweile
salon fliegt worden und ich weiß auch
nicht warum aber ich
habe in dem moment einfach nur gedacht
ich muss irgendwas ich bin raus aus dem
hotel ich wollte eigentlich leicht gehen
damit man das sogar noch leipzig aber
irgendwie kam ich nicht ins netz und hat
mir einfach immer gesagt und jetzt noch
ein video und das habe ich getan die
ganze nacht lag ich eigentlich bach in
einem anderen hotel im bett und
möchte mich nochmals bedanken bei meyle
jedermann
so schnell reagiert haben mich da auch
abgeholt haben
jedenfalls beim nächsten mal ich mir
gesagt jetzt musst du das posten das
musste einfach machen und die reaktionen
sind so wie sie eigentlich sein sollten
die menschen sind empört ich bekomme
wahnsinnig viele e mails und und
zuschriften von menschen die sagen das
geht nicht sie schämen sich und ich
möchte auch mal sagen ich glaube nicht
dass das gesamte hotel so ein
gedankengut verbreitet aber
ich bin fassungslos ich würde mir
wünschen dass mehr menschen aufstehen
würden solidarität ist super es freut
mich sehr aber so ein post schnell wie
posten online ist schnell passiert aber
was passiert danach ist es dann wieder
ein paar tagen verpufft ich hoffe nicht
denn sowas auch in der vergangenheit und
das darf nicht sein
mitarbeiter des hotels das sich bei
ihnen offiziell noch nicht entschuldigt
hat sie haben es vorhin gesagt haben
sich dann vor die tür gestellt haben
israelische flaggen in der hand gehalten
aber auch flaggen mit islamischen
symbolen wie haben sie diese aktion
aufgenommen
ich muss ihnen ehrlich sage ich ja
wieder den fernseher angemacht gestern
großartig netz gesagt ich sie können
verstehen mein handy ist gestern durch
fast explodiert und die nachrichten aber
es ist eine kleine message nicht sagt
nur ein jurist nicht gleichzeitig auch
israeli also das eine hat nichts mit dem
anderen was zu tun aber
ich habe mich gefreut dass ich gehört
dass viele menschen spontan abend vor
das total gegangen sind und ein zeichen
setzen wollten und das hat mir viel
bedeutet und
das netz ist nicht nur in deutschland
ist gerade weltweit und
ich hoffe noch mal ich sage es nochmal
ist darf ich sagen wir haben 20 21 ich
hoffe jetzt passiert irgendwas ich weiß
nicht wie ich habe kein rezept dagegen
ich kann mir nur vorstellen
es hat vielleicht weil er bei der
aufklärung bei der bildung in der schule
ich weiß es nicht aber ich bitte die
menschen da draußen wenn irgendjemand
etwas mitbekommt nicht einfach nur
dastehen oder sich umdrehen sondern
handeln was sagen ich glaube das ist
auch genau der richtige weg den sie
jetzt gehen um das einfach öffentlich zu
machen wir haben im übrigen auch das
hotel nach einer stellungnahme gefragt
und das wurde uns gesagt wir haben mal
kurz rein
ich würde direkt noch mal fragen warum
gibt es denn noch kein statement ab
obwohl auch das sozialministerium von
sachsen mittlerweile und andere fordern
eine aufklärung ich möchte nicht gefilmt
werden erst mal ich bin hier im
mitarbeitern daher bitte nicht gefilmt
werden es ist unmöglich den
hoteldirektor jetzt zu sprechen ich kann
gerne nachfragen und momentan bin mit
canon städten dazu abgeben dann fragen
sie doch mal nach danke
mittlerweile hat sich das hotel übrigens
doch zu dem vorfall vom montagabend
geäußert allerdings nur schriftlich und
ich zitiere mal kurz wir sind ein
weltoffenes hotel und lehnen jede form
von intoleranz diskriminierung und
antisemitismus auf das schärfste ab
deshalb sind wir über die unerträglichen
vorwürfe von herrn ewering besorgt und
alarmiert
antisemitismus ist nicht entschuldbar
und wird in unser hotel nicht geduldet
so die reaktion des hotels was sagen sie
dazu rufen
also bei mir
gemeldet aber schön
gesagt wird ich hoffe nur dass es stimmt
und dass auch was passiert das ist alles
was ich machen kann das hotel hat auch
weiter dass sie versucht haben mit ihnen
kontakt aufzunehmen
stimmt das nicht und dem betreffenden
mitarbeiter beurlaubt haben davon weiß
ich nichts ich weiß nur dass späten
nachmittag war mein management gemeldet
haben aber noch mal mit keiner
stellungnahme mit keiner ich will schon
gar nicht von einer entschuldigung reden
aber
die wollen nur reden das tanzen die
würden gerne mit mir persönlich sprechen
also ist alles andere ist nicht passiert
erfahren ganz herzlichen dank für ihre
offenen worte hier und irgend wichtigen
appell danke danke schön
[Musik]